هذا وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ان بلاده قدمت وستواصل تقديم وثائق الى
محكمه العدل الدوليه تسهم في الدعوه التي
رفعتها جنوب افريقيا ضد اسرائيل وعرب
اردوغان في التصريحات للصحفيين في اسطنبول
عن تقته بعداله المحكمه وبان اسرائيل
ستدان في هذه
القضيه
فقط الوثائق التي قدمناها ضد اسرائ يكون
لها دور جدي في محكمه العد الدوليه في هاي
وسنستمر في تقديم المزيد من الوثائق نحن
مؤمنون بعداله المحكمه وبانها ستدين
اسرائيل لا اعرف باي وجه تدافع اسرائيل عن
نفسها بينما هي تحول المنطقه الاكثر
اكتظاظا في العالم الى بحر من الدماء
وتقتل ما يزيد على 22 الف شهيد في اكبر
سجن مفتوح في العالم ليس امام نتنياهو اي
مهرب من العداله وليست له اي وسيله للدفاع
عن نفسه كنت ارى ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاق ستوك اكثر صدقا لكنه في الاونه
الاخيره اصبح يتبع نتنياهو بتصريحاته
الغريبه